[Music]
oops was a bit late hello and welcome to
this video more my table ah that's
probably a wrong way to pronounce it
okay once you form go for an English
opening let's try something else
entirely
Oh d5 interesting hmm you don't see that
often what is the reasoning there should
be five problem
I'm okay yeah basically after so let's
see how to play that position there are
there are two basic things that you can
do it you can try to play against the
structure or you can try to exploit the
advantage in development and I'm going
for the development advantage how does
he handle this c6 is attacked and I have
95 you know I made a mistake because I
was thinking I have 95 but that is of
course not true because the Queen takes
Queen c6 candiate the knight is
protecting the rook so my whole idea
here was wrong so my position now is
that said still okay or not
I think d4 is the way to do it I have to
try to exploit the development advantage
now with 95 impossible that her way of
playing is probably not so great and I
could have done the other strategy just
play against the pawns slowly I will see
what happens it's not entirely clear
this whole thing I have 95 on the agenda
in 95 really that is good it's tough to
believe even after Knight takes how do
you save your palm from do you doomed
I mean Pontius was interesting as well
but how do you save your porn now and
I'm also threatening rook t1 Wow
really that seems like a true it seems a
bit ignorant to be honest like you're
getting killed in the center and
Blackfeet feels it's time to play h5
that's that's tough I wonder if there is
a playable move still oh this looks
difficult really
how are you not getting killed now
Knight takes c6 and resigns
yeah I was a short one yeah this move is
very uncommon actually against e3 they
all play a six or sometimes g6 the the
reason you can almost only be this one
because other things would transpose
like d4 d-46 is a semi to rush this
probably has to be this move
yeah Knight see settlements I think a
bit surprising there's really no need to
retreat the night and yeah so I castles
and yeah yeah you can play this the way
I did and the engine actually likes it
as I seen the the alternative is to just
play against the pawns like with b3 and
not go go for this but h3 seems to be
fine as the engine gives this this Queen
a foil is strong okay I mean it is I did
not see you I really was thinking I can
play 95 which is ridiculous they just
blunders a full-piece the knight is
covering this but d4 is strong I mean
I'm basically catching black here being
so much behind in development that it's
going to be very difficult to get a
playable position 95 is supposed to be
best so that's already a pretty grim law
and if you have to play C for him just
to prevent further opening over the
position
okay so takes I looked you wanna seem
stronger but Knight takes it's not bad
and now h5 is an extremely like yeah no
no no ignorant is kind of too unfriendly
or something but it's just like not
addressing anything it's probably
difficult to keep this put this together
anyway the engines gives 96
relatively less smooth just grabbing
here is not so clear I mean it's a pawn
that at least you're not getting
checkmated the computer likes this fast
it seems and okay if you once you see
that you understand the reasoning yeah
there is a safe way at five coming very
nice
yeah and h5 rook t1 is just over +5 just
have no move available there was a bit
of an opening catastrophe yeah it's
important to not shy away from moves
like g4 by the way I know it looks
always a little bit riskier to advance
upon but you need in order to to get
this concept rolling and I know I did it
because I saw a blonde that basically in
my mind but so if I want to play on the
advantage I have to play this g4 stuff
because Queen a form Bishop f3 this is
not good for me now this is always too
annoying so you have to play g4 and push
to push this off side this is important
the bishop is the piece that is missing
in the defense of the light squares on
the Queen side so it is unimportant that
the King is weakened it's just very very
concrete and yeah again I 95 is
ridiculous but d4 is strong it just it
opens up everything and black if it will
have a hard time to defend as we also
saw in the variations thanks a lot for
watching